Je n'ai pas beaucoup de temps et
j'apprécie que vous répondiez aux
questions que le
président Trump a indiqué sa conviction
que le changement climatique est un canular
peut-être perpétré par les Chinois êtes-
vous bien d'accord Je crois que le
changement climatique est réel Je crois que  l'homme a un
impact là-dessus et le président a dit que le
changement climatique est un canular êtes-vous d'accord
avec lui je n'ai pas utilisé le mot canular moi-
même gentiment êtes-vous d'accord avec la
communauté scientifique que le changement climatique
est une crise mondiale qui doit être
traitée en  d'une manière agressive, je crois
que le changement climatique est un problème mondial
qui doit être traité à l'échelle mondiale, aucun
pays ne peut répondre à ma question, Sir
Michael, je n'ai pas beaucoup de temps et
j'apprécie que vous répondiez aux
questions que la communauté scientifique a posées.  le
changement climatique est l'une des grandes
crises auxquelles notre planète est confrontée et s'il
n'y a pas d'action sans précédent pour transformer
notre système énergétique des combustibles fossiles
en énergie durable et en efficacité énergétique,
il y aura des dommages irréparables aux
États-Unis et dans pratiquement tous les
pays de la planète.  vous êtes d'accord avec la
communauté scientifique, je ne l'appellerais pas
la plus grande crise non monsieur, je considère un
énorme problème qui doit être résolu à
l'échelle mondiale, bien ce que vous êtes, j'ai trouvé cela
intéressant m.  Wheeler, vous êtes le
candidat à la tête de l'
Agence de protection de l'environnement, vous venez de dire que dans votre
déclaration liminaire, vous n'avez pas mentionné le
mot changement climatique si le
peuple américain a confiance que vous allez
nous aider à faire face à cette crise mondiale
oui, ils devraient avoir confiance  parce que
nous allons de l'avant pour réduire le co2 maintenant,
nous sommes l'économie la plus forte du
monde et si la direction de l'
agence de protection de l'environnement aux
États-Unis dit à la Chine et à la
Russie et à l'Inde et aux pays
du monde entier que nous avons  d'agir de
manière agressive pour protéger cette planète pour
nos enfants et nos petits-enfants, nous
pouvons avoir un impact sur l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale êtes-vous prêt
à le faire
je suis nous mettons en œuvre les lois que le
Congrès a adoptées est-ce que l'élévation du niveau de la mer est
une préoccupation ou est-ce  un canular
l'élévation du niveau de la mer est une préoccupation et nous
croyons en l'adaptation et nous examinons l'
adaptation du patient, je suis désolé, pour aider à l'élévation du niveau de la mer,
sauf en l'absence d'une autorité supplémentaire du Congrès,
mais vous tous oui, le point est
d'accord sont  les gens ici qui ne
croient pas au changement climatique mais vous
allez être le leader peut-être de la
protection de l'environnement nous avons besoin de votre
aide maintenant est l'élévation réelle du niveau de la mer qu'allons-
nous faire pour minimiser cela
ce que nous allons faire est sont  les
incendies de forêt que nous avons vus en
Californie et ailleurs
oh sont ceux liés au changement climatique
à votre avis, il y a probablement une
relation avec le changement climatique Je pense que le
plus gros problème avec les incendies de forêt a
été la gestion forcée, c'est le
plus gros problème, pas les
sécheresses qui  nous constatons que c'est le
plus gros problème, pas les sécheresses à mon
avis oui d'accord merci beaucoup